je trouve que cette loi est décrite est
volontairement de manière de manière
assez floue de façon à ce que chaque
concurrent de la république puisse
rentrer en boîte poursuite tout
simplement et de dirhams un ancien
journaliste qui se serait attrapé sur la
voie publique ou après en ayant diffusé
des images pour pouvoir dire nous
rentrons en boîte poursuites
voilà je trouve que le cadre le cadre
elle été laissée traîtresse où les
contours planète ce qui permettrait aux
thomas à n'importe quel magistrat de se
saisir d'une procédure judiciaire est
d'incriminer un journaliste ou une
personne lambda sur la voie publique
pour avoir filmé des policiers c'est
cette imprécision de la loi mais qui
encore une fois est tout à fait et tout
à fait prévu il s'astreignait requis
fonds permettrait vraiment sur le
terrain de poursuivre et de condamner
notamment des journalistes qui ont fait
des images du policy